[Music]
so next up we have
javier laroski from our studio thank you
very much join me in welcoming him
thank you everyone uh today i'm really
excited because we're going to be
talking about three things we're going
to be talking about
spark ml flow and a new project called
delta lake
so we're going to get started it's going
to go fast so
what about spark if you've never heard
about spark this is what you need to
know
mostly there's a lot of data in this
world the world bank reports that
actually data is working
is growing exponentially basically
around every two years you can expect
that we have twice as much data
and you know what do you do when you
have a lot of data well
you can try a lot of things like first
of all sampling your data sets
using tools like arrow getting a bigger
machine lots of different things but
when all fails
what you can do is split your data into
multiple into multiple machines
and you can do that with something
called hadoop which was a very popular
tool for many years
uh but if you want to even kind of like
provide better performance
and much more functionality a better
replacement for hadoop
the runtime is apache spark so that's
kind of like the intro
um if you want to use spark on on r like
what do you
what do what do you do is well you use
the sparkly r package
and the great thing about the spark vr
package is that if you're already
familiar with the plier
you can basically reuse all your
deployer code and then
add a couple lines on top of it and read
the data in a distributed fashion and
still use the plier to
scale your data sets so that's pretty
great and it also works in a similar way
with packages like broom
rlank expressions and dbi so how exactly
do you use
sparkly r well first of all if you don't
have a cluster with a bunch of machines
and a bunch of budget
don't worry all you need to do is run
spark install and that's basically going
to install a local version of spark
in your local machine and then you use
spark connect to connect to the cluster
either locally
or if you happen to have like yarn mesos
kubernetes or whatever
you change the master parameter to the
location of your cluster
then you can read and write data um you
know on csv file formats
parquet from arrows a great way of
interoperating
avro json and a bunch of others like
databases
you can also do data analysis with tools
that you already know and love
like sql using the dbi package or dplyr
and you can run over 50 machine learning
algorithms and feature transformers
using the mlev
library which is provided by default on
spark
you can also grab those models and
extract them out in a pipeline
and then you can use those pipelines in
production or push them to python
or java enabled devices and um
you can also build extensions we can't
obviously provide support for all the
functionality
that you might want so you can write
extensions for spark and r
in scala or you can also use r
extensions using spark apply
and last but not least one of the latest
features added to spark
was spark structured streaming which
basically allows you to process
real-time data sets in spark
with the same set of functions and also
using the things like the plier
all right so what what have we been up
to well
we started the sparkly r project back in
2016
and since then we've obviously added a
bunch of features but i think it's more
interesting to highlight
that there's a bunch of product products
and cloud services that have embraced
sparkly r
a different degree some of them have
provided blog posts and documentation on
how to use it
some other cloud providers like
databricks and cubal have actually added
first class support
in sparkly r for uh for their clusters
which is pretty great
at the last release of spark was spark
1-0
where we added support for apache arrow
and yes we did got
40 times performance improvements as
neil was mentioning
so that's pretty great it's still
optional so you don't get arrow by
default you need to install the arrow
package and then use it
and sparkly r01 also added support for
xgboost
broom and tf records uh the talk today
is more about sparkly r101 which we just
released to cran
and one of the new features that sparkly
r 101 adds
is support for delta lake so what is
delta lake
delta lake is a new open source project
which happens to be
hosted with the linux foundation and
what it
adds it it gives spark the ability to
have
acid transactions which is basically
database like properties to use on top
of your
data lake uh now this doesn't mean that
you should use
this doesn't mean that you should
replace your databases with spark that's
not at all the goal of this project
but what it really allows you to do is
to mix real-time data with batch
processing data on the same table
so in the past our studio conference i
had to do this demo where we use
different types of functions and
to load data streaming data against
patch data and basically
you can replace all that with delta lake
because you don't need to worry about
where the data is coming from it just
goes to the same
source and it also enables a few nice
features like being able to find
and use previous versions of your data
sets um which we'll see in a second
so how do you use delta lake from r you
need to load the sparkly r package and
then you connect as usual
but there's a new parameter called
packages so you want to specify packages
equals delta and then you basically say
use the functions to read and write data
you say
spark write delta and you write a data
frame here we have a huge data frames
with
three rows and we're replacing that huge
data frame with
another data frame with one row and
basically then if you ask
delta lake for that particular data set
you just say spark with delta
and you get that data set right with one
row but what is interesting is you can
also tell
us delta hey give me the previous
version that i
just overgrowed and what that would give
you back is the three records that were
initially there
all right so more new features in
sparkly r 101 uh well first of all these
are community extensions
so super exciting to see the community
growing and building extensions on top
of sparkly are
there is two extensions on the genomic
space so if you're into genomics
there's one called variant spark for
doing genome-wide association studies
and one initial extension for
using hail from spark which is currently
in cran
but still probably still needs a few
more releases to
be fully usable and there's another
extension called spark nlp if you're in
into natural language processing that's
extension that you want to check out
and you can take a look at all the
extensions or at least some of them
under a new github repo
it's a github.com our spark
a few more features on sparkly r101
cue ball is as i mentioned added support
for
sparkly r on their clusters so if you
happen to be a
customer of cubel in order to use
sparkly r from those clusters
all you need to say is spark connect
method equals cubal
for those of you using data breaks this
is very similar to what
we already have which is uh to connect
to databricks you would say
method equals data breaks and that's
pretty much it it's quite quite simple
and straightforward
um there's also spark 3.0 about to be
released at some point this year
um it's currently on preview so that
means that you don't want to use it for
production
but uh basically if you if you can't
wait to try it out or you have workflows
that you're planning to move to
spark 3.0 this is a great way of trying
it out it
it adds new features features like
support for java 11
gpu scheduling and also binary files
so how do you use it from sparkly r uh
well what you would do is
basically you want to say spark install
and then 3.0 preview
and that installs the 3.0 version the
preview version of 3.0 in your local
machine
and then you just connect to spark 3.0
we have a long tail of box so it's
definitely you know if you find issues
let us know and we'll um we'll fix them
and uh in this particular example what
we're doing is we're downloading
imagenet well actually a subset of
imagenet called tiny imagenet
and we're using the pins package to
download it and then we're loading that
data set into spark by using a new
feature called binary
file which basically gives you a data
frame with images in each row which you
can use for
deep learning or why not and uh this
brings me to
the last feature which is pretty pretty
geeky but i'm really excited about it
so one of the new kind of like trends
that the spark community has been
noticing
is that if you look at the
state-of-the-art deep learning models
a lot of them uh the you know several
years ago they all were trained with a
single gpu
but if you look at newer models like
alphago or the
open ai's v versus one v one v or
whatever it's called
uh v v one one v one uh model
they all use m use more than one gpu to
get trained
and uh spark trying to be this a
platform that allows you to run
distributed workloads it's adding
support for something called barrier
execution
which basically all it does it gives
control back to the
cluster machines that you're using for
you to run either openmp
or tensorflow distributed or why not so
don't expect to use this user uh don't
expect to use this feature on your own
um but you know like if your advanced
user or maybe ourself will create
extensions on top of these that makes
use of this functionality but if you if
you had to use it you basically use
spark apply
you say barrier equals true and then
what you get is you know in this case
it's just a single machine you would get
basically the ip addresses
and the ports that you can use to
directly communicate to those machines
all right so uh we're going to switch to
mlflow and before we
uh kind of like explain what ml flow is
i want to kind of like present what's
the problem that mlflow is trying to
solve
and for that i want to use a quote from
andre karpati which
leads the self-driving effort at tesla
and
in one of his talks he mentioned that
you know like the stack for software 2.0
doesn't exist
so so what does that mean so if you
think of companies like for instance
netflix right they have a bunch of image
of
they have a bunch of movies and they
need to do data science on those
movies and to create a recommendation
algorithm for you to
you know to choose a movie to watch uh
companies like apple with siri they need
to
you know like do models around speech
processing and companies like tesla need
to take capture images and then train
deep learning models on top of them so
you're probably familiar with this you
know this is the standard
kind of like data science approach where
you get a data set and you create a
model out of that
but then something that you can consider
is also well if i already have this
model maybe i can
make it part of my product so things
that netflix does for instance is like
they don't only create a recommendation
model but they deploy
their recommendation model to their
website right so you see
the model being deployed there if you're
apple and you're using siri you also
have a model deployed on your phone
and if you're tesla and you're building
self-driving less cars you also deploy
that model to
your cars so now you have models in
production
so what do we do what do you do with
those well you usually want to collect
data because there's a bunch of data
that is meaningful to get either from
your actual things that you're watching
on netflix or why not
and once you have the data you kind of
like want to tidy it because this data
is usually pretty messy
and you bring it back to the beginning
and the problem that this creates is
that you
you usually don't only have one model
you have multiple models
you have multiple parameters that you're
using to throw in your models you have
multiple versions of the data and you
have multiple
versions of the code so it can be pretty
easy to get into a quite quite a mess
while you're trying to uh you know like
do this faster and faster
uh so the amo flow project basically is
an open source platform to manage the
machine learning life cycle
and you can use it from are as follows
it has three main features
ml flow tracking mo flow projects animal
flow models
tracking basically tracks your
parameters and your metrics
projects allows you to deploy to
production your models
and the modeling component of this
project allows you to
perform inference on the models in this
particular example all we're using is
the tracking component of ammo flow
and you know like we're basically saying
start a new ammo flow experiment
then we lock some parameters and we lock
some metrics
so um kind of like to put all this
together let's just take a quick look
at how how this all works together and
now it doesn't mean that you need to use
spark ml flow and
delta lake together you can use them
separately right but in this particular
demo we're gonna
basically use all of them at the same
time so we're first of all we're we're
defining some helper functions and then
we're connecting to spark
and we're saying package equals delta
which is the component that we mentioned
is required when um when connecting to
spark
and then what we're going to do is we're
going to download a data set with
uh you know the attracts wine quality
we're using the pins package for that
then we're reading it
as a csv and spark and then we're
grinding it to delta now you usually
wouldn't do this you usually have a big
data set already
but just for the purposes of this demo
this is what we're doing
so now the data is being written to
delta lake and then what we can do is we
can use spark
to first of all log which is the version
of our data that we're using
you can also uh log some of the
parameters that we're going to be using
in uh
in this case using glm
on spark so we're logging the parameters
that our model is using
we are and we're also logging the actual
metrics
and you get that for free it's automatic
and then you can you can use it so
suppose now that you know like
we we didn't really like the performance
of this model
and then it also happened to be the case
that someone came along and replaced our
data set or new
or new data became available so we have
two things changing one is
the actual data set and we also change
our model and we're going to rerun it
and again this is this is mostly
transparent once you start using mlflow
you you're logging all these
but the great thing is that you can
actually track these metrics
by using the mlflow ui and
you can take a look at here and we have
two runs that we just performed
one of them has a lambda of o5 and it's
using the version
of delta lake one of the data of the
data frame
and then we also have our previous run
you can see here that you have things
like
you know some metrics and then you can
you can drill down and look at
this particular experiment and open up
and look at it and say like wow this is
looking great
and so you can add a node looking great
and you can also look at the metrics uh
you know our
our particular run was pretty small but
if you if this was like a pretty long
run you could actually long
log the progress and see progress
towards it
all right so that covers kind of like
everything else and uh there's
two more things that i want to share so
i know that there's a lot to learn
you know in order to learn spark and all
these things in one 20 minute talk is
impossible
so if you feel a little bit lost don't
worry we have you covered
we growed a book with o'reilly this book
that you can just go and purchase it's
called mastering spark with r
it's on your favorite local store or
online and
mostly it's it's a great resource for
you to learn spark
uh you can basically if you don't know
anything about spark whatsoever
just grab the book and read it start to
finish if you're an intermediate user
that's also fine you probably will find
tips and tricks that you didn't know
about and
if you don't feel like buying it that's
also completely okay you can go to the
rnspark.com
and it's free to use there uh for you
and uh last but not least i want to kind
of like
give a big shout out of thank you to the
art community
the sparkly art project honestly is just
successful because of the art community
and uh there has been a lot of momentum
going on
there's over 20 community extensions
created for the
sparkly art project and there's over 50
contributors
but most most interestingly there has
one
thing that has changed in the last six
the last three months
kind of is that while our studio keeps
being one of the main
committers and uh supporters of the
sparkly r project
uh there is interest for other entities
like cubal and databricks
adding new features like spark 3.0 which
was provided by databricks
and you know like also you know a lot of
good um
uh collaboration going on with the ursa
labs project and apache arrow
so we definitely want to uh take uh
sparkly r
uh to you know to be uh to even grow
broader with our community and beyond
the art community
so the other announcement that we have
for today is that um sparkly r is
joining
the linux foundation under the lfi lfi
umbrella
uh this basically doesn't change
anything as a user but as a contributor
it changes a lot because basically that
means that
you know it should be much easier to
contribute it's also
hosted with the linux within the linux
foundation which
provides open governance and holds the
some of the project assets
and you know other projects have trusted
the linux foundation like
kubernetes delta lag node.js horovod and
even linux itself
so um yeah if you want to learn more
about it go to our
sassy url sparklyr.ei and uh thank you
thanks for that great talk we've got a
number of questions on
slido so how will ml flow interact with
tidy models
the thai models ecosystem yeah i mean
that's a great question i mean the
reality
right now is that ml flow is pretty bare
bones as you noticed like you basically
have to do everything on your own you
need to say
elmo flow log so there's no interaction
whatsoever
but it's definitely something on our
radar that we would want to do so much
better so i'm i'm sure we'll come up
with something but right now
you need to lock manually the parameters
are the ml functions that run in a local
spark instance
automatically multi-threaded or do we
still need to use things like 4-h
mc apply et cetera no it's actually
multi-threaded
so you can use spark locally and there
there might be some very few use cases
for using spark on a single instance on
your local machine
but i honestly don't recommend it
because spark was designed to run
on clusters so yes you might get some
performance improvements in some cases
but
that's not the main use case for spark
anyways yep
so this is an interesting question are
there plans to make ml flow more
enterprise friendly with things like
authentication permissions etc
uh you should ask that question to
tariff if he's somewhere in here but
not not to my knowledge i know that i
know that data breaks at support has
support for ml flow so
if you're a databricks customer it's
quite easy to use ammo flow on their
platform but if not
i think you'll have to hack something
together at least for now
thank you
you